we always love it when we can say only
on cbs mornings especially when it comes
to revealing the latest selection in
oprah's book club her new pick is called
that my bird has my wings the
autobiography of an innocent man on
death row it's written by jarvis j
masters is his name and more than 20
years ago masters was sentenced to death
by lethal injection for a crime he was
never accused of committing you're me
right never accused of committing our
lead national correspondent david
begnell spoke with oprah about why she
picked this book and then he also
interviewed masters from outside
california's san quentin state prison
the man who's now the centerpiece pick
of oprah's book club lives deep inside
of san quentin california's oldest
prison my name is joris masters i've
been in san quentin for 35 years this
video of jarvis j masters from 2016
provides a rare look at the place that
holds the largest population of death
row inmates in the country step back
away from the sale please there's no way
to show you more because it's against
california law to bring cameras into
state prisons to interview a specific
prisoner but inmates may call out you
have a prepaid call from the jarvis
masters an inmate at the california
state prison san quentin hello jarvis
good morning hey is this david how are
you doing i am well how are you feeling
this morning
well you know i'm nervous for sure
nervous why
paris because i'm talking to cbs i mean
who does that you know
jarvis masters arrived at san quentin in
1981 from long beach california
where police first picked up the runaway
boy at the age of six he'd been
abandoned by his mother and father
and that life prepared him for prison
gang life tell me about this armed
robbery that you committed
which ones
how many were there
there were a bunch of them i got
convicted of maybe 14 15.
wow
i had ran away from the youth authority
i just needed the money you've written
two books finding freedom that bird has
my wings that bird has my wings is the
reason we are talking today it was
picked for oprah's book club
what was your intention for writing that
book
my intention for writing that book was
to speak to the kids people who were at
risk i saw all those faces in that book
when i wrote it more and more i began
feeling like i was telling their story
as well as mine this call and to our
telephone number will be monitored and
recorded and it's interesting oprah
because when you interview an inmate you
only have about six minutes and then the
phone cuts off and they have to call
back were you you were able to talk to
him and actually hear his voice yeah wow
jarvis masters how did you first hear
the name i was interviewing pima
children the buddhist monk spiritual
teacher pima children wrote the
introduction i kept wanting things to go
differently for this
promising young boy but the blunt truth
is that things didn't go differently and
she suggested that i read the book and
that was i think around
2014 over eight years ago
i read the book
loved the book wanted to choose the book
as a book club then
or at least get an interview with him
then
i called the then governor of california
i appealed to the entire prison system i
wrote letters i called my team called we
could not get an interview jarvis
masters now a buddhist wrote about his
journey from a hardened street kid whose
life took an even more terrible turn
four years into his 20-year armed
robbery sentence
that's when prison guard howell dean
birchfield was killed by inmates in a
single stab wound to the heart
and though jarvis masters was never
accused of committing the murder he was
accused of making the device to commit
the crime i was charged with it i never
understood why i was charged for it
really didn't try to put up with defense
you know i was 20 something years old
yeah i know this is going to sound
strange to people but you know at that
time i wanted to
leave the prison and then go to a
courtroom
did you have anything to do with making
the tool the instrument that was used to
kill him
absolutely not
no
the record shows at the 1990 court
sentencing that the judge said quote he
was born into hell he was born for
reasons it is almost impossible for me
to comprehend if people don't want
children they shouldn't have them
apparently his mother didn't know how to
not have them
[Music]
and he's now in his 60s
and that statement still sticks with him
today
wouldn't it stick for somebody saying
not only somebody but somebody who's
sentencing you to death saying you
should have never even been born i said
to him on the call
jarvis what happened to you
wow and his voice changed and he said oh
man
and he took us back to long beach at 12
i was arrested for committing the first
crime and he said i was a young boy when
i walked into the house and i heard that
my latest foster mom and stepdad were
telling the social worker they were
seriously ill and that the boy would
have to leave and he said it was the
first time i thought
oh no i don't want to leave this place
and that just
turned my world upside down even before
i got into these other foster homes you
know
i felt betrayed you know what was it in
the book
that really
sparked a fire for you one of the things
that
sparked the fire for me
he talks about the thing that carried
him through life was
holding on to the love that people had
shared with him in spite of you know his
mother being a heroin addict in spite of
all the crazy violent things that were
happening in their house and and and
that moment you believe that no matter
what my mother loves me no matter how
many times you've been abandoned it's
the love
that carries you through it's the love
that allows you to
in the end fulfill yourself and so his
ability to even reform himself came from
understanding that somewhere inside
there was enough still there worthy of
love so some people will hear this and
say a death row inmate oprah's book club
what what's the intention behind the
pick
you know that's my favorite word
number one my intention is to expose the
story
number two my intention is to let people
know that there are a lot of people on
death row and a lot of people in prison
for whom there has been a miscarriage of
justice and in this case i believe there
has been a miscarriage of justice i do
not believe
that the crime that he is on death row
for
that he was involved in or committed
oprah winfrey has gone so far as to help
find a team of defense lawyers that is
now led by michael williams an attorney
with kirkland and ellis the world's
largest law firm at the time that jarvis
was convicted the state of california
had in their possession
a confession by another individual
saying that he had committed the crime
not jarvis
these are three people critically
involved in the case that's right and it
was their testimony that was used to
convict jarvis masters yes when you have
an innocent man on death row it's not
just one person who said something that
was wrong the people who were now saying
that jarvis didn't do it
are the key crucial characters who were
actually convicted of doing it yes or
pleaded to doing it so the case was
built on the words of these people
exactly and now their words are changing
exactly now their words have long since
changed
and we have
a judge appointed by the california
supreme court who said
yes i've heard that they've changed
their testimony true
but
that just shows that they're not
credible
and so why should i believe them well
then why should we believe the
conviction was right in the first place
that's exactly our point the jarvis i'm
speaking to now sounds like a soft
reflective man
the jarvis you're telling me about seems
scary and intimidating what changed you
i think what changed me is becoming 23
and now becoming 60
and everything in between that yes
buddhism helped me it really really
exposed the suffering that we all live
inside of
growing up inside the violence
here
knowing what violence does to people
it changed you you know just change you
you have 60 seconds remaining part of
the reason that his story is so
extraordinary is because he has been
living in hell for 40 years you know
people who
are on death row you know people go
crazy they kill themselves they become
really cynical and bitter and angry and
he did the opposite david chef an
award-winning author who wrote the book
the buddhist on death row
says he found evidence that jarvis
masters has helped people while in
prison so jarvis embraced this
new path of committing himself to trying
to alleviate suffering in every way that
he could he stopped
at least two people from being stabbed
in the yard and why was he able to look
in the face of a prison guard and see
this guard's
anguish and reach out to help him you
know why did he
intervene when this guy who was this gay
kid who was brought into the prison who
absolutely was going to be killed and
yet at a time when he could have been
killed for intervening he stepped up and
he got in the way of this do you think
he's innocent i'm 100 convinced he's
innocent i've read it all
i believe that if he had had real
representation that he never would have
been convicted given all the pain you
endured as a child
given the decades that you've spent in
prison and on death row
has your life been worth it
that's a good question i'm glad that my
mother gave me a chance
i'm glad she gave me a chance
jarvis do you think he'll die in prison
one day i i swear to god i don't think
i'm getting out of here next day i think
i'm getting out you know and they go
back and forth my whole trip is how do i
accept both possibilities both outcomes
and live with that
jarvis master's next step to arguing for
his exoneration is going to take place
in a hearing in federal court on october
27th the state of california's attorney
general's office will have a chance to
then counter but in response to our
request for an interview the state wrote
that it refused to answer our questions
i know oprah's been talking about this
story for years i still don't understand
why he is on death row still
you it's fascinating gail in that he's
the guy who's on death row but he was
never accused of actually committing the
murder exactly and the people who
actually were convicted of committing
the crime are not on death row exactly
that for starters is like wait what
right it's very strange and it's a
reminder that you always talk about
guilty without a shadow of doubt i mean
the shadow over the criminal justice
system in general is pretty large at
this point and it's troubling look and
he's been trying he's got a powerhouse
defense team now they're going to go to
the federal court system and basically
say the state aired and at the end of
the day if the federal court system
decides that his constitutional rights
were violated jarvis masters has already
served his sentence for armed robbery so
if his conviction is thrown out he
essentially is a free man could be
released wow that's let's see what
happens no one wants criminals to go
free but at the same time you don't want
innocent people to be serving beyond
what they should
all right david thank you very much
that's a great piece and a great
selection for the new oprah book club
pick